tunisia's president has named a
political outsider to be the country's
first female prime minister najla buden
has been named has been tasked with
forming a new transitional government
though its authority is likely to be
limited president kai saeed has expanded
his hold on power after sacking the
previous government in july that's
raised fears that the country could be
heading into authoritarian rule
german chancellor angela merkel stressed
the importance of tunisia's young
democracy when she spoke to said by
phone on wednesday
a historic appointment in a time of
crisis
president kaii saeed has tasked najila
buddha with bringing change to tunisian
politics
we will work together in the future
with a steadfast determination
the legislature and granted himself
emergency powers in july
measures he said were necessary during
the economic crisis and protests over
pandemic management
but opponents accuse him of a coup and
say he is a threat to democracy
[Applause]
the new prime minister is a geology
professor with little government
experience
news of her appointment has come with
mixed reactions in tunisia
we don't know what she will do
okay
it's an important step because she is a
woman and all that
but that doesn't mean that it's good
women don't take bribes
they're not susceptible to blackmail
they work and provide their services in
all fields
she has brought us honor in the whole
world
but after the president granted himself
emergency powers it's unclear just how
much authority buddha will be able to
exert